MATTHEWS SQUARES OFF AGAINST
CROS
THE LEAD LEAGUE IN GOALS!H A QU
RELEASE.
ALMOST AN IMPOSSIBLE SAVE TO
MAKE.
WHAT A GREAT S MIKE MIKE SULLIV
CROSBY LINE.
WITH HOLL AND DERMOTT.AN'T PINC.
A SLOW START THERE BY LETANG WHO
GAVE IT AWAY. HANDLED THEKAWAY!
CAMPBELL WITH A STOP.
LOST HIS STICK AND
FOUR ALONG WITH NYLANDER.
LOOKING TO GET BACK IN THE
CHECKING OF  ICING.
BUNTING CHASES
AGO.
THAT ONE WENT OFF THE ANKLE. WO
TALK ABOUT AGAIN.
>> Craig: BEAUTY.ALF MINUTE TO .
KASE WITH SHOVEL PASS THAT TO
THE SLOTE HE MAKES A SPLIT
DECISION, THAHA LINE FOR THE
PENGUINS.
WRAPS IT AROUND TO T AROUND THE.
AND FEE
REMAINING AS PITTSBURGH GETS IT
TIGHT.
WASN'T ABLE TO GET IT
UPOSBY WATCHED BY SPEZZA.
HE HAS TO STATA
YET.
BREAKAWAY!ACT THAT THE NET
ISN'T IN RIGHT POSITION, IT'S
THAT PRESSURE BYCHRIS, WHERE  D
THE PITTSBURGH ZONE.
PLAYING IN
DOESN'T PLAY THE RIGHT SIDE.SAN.
NOW, YOU'VE GOT A
PERFORM KWANSANCESANCES
PERFORMANC FOR
BUNTING.
IT CAME OFF THEINED BY HIS USUAY
BUT NOT YET.HARD.
INTERESTING TO LISTEN TO SHELDON